ah
[Musique]
bah voilà
ah oui paix qui les lie voilà il ça il
fait mine de 2,2 d'apporter quelque
chose
et ils s'installent
le clown c'est un masque est aussi
d'abord donc c'est une certaine approche
de la présence au plateau loin de l'idée
de composition avant tout on parle
vraiment de la personne telle qu'elle
apparaît avec son physique sa voix
au quotidien quand on arrive sur un
plateau on va d'abord faire des
exercices de voix des exercices de
respiration de mouvement et puis sinon
il ya ce travail du coeur avec eux ce
tracé du cercle au sol pour faire des
gammes avant ou de jouets ont bien
improvisé s'est résumée la condition
humaine
est la condition du vivant on a à coeur
de porter des projets où la figure du
clown et centrale où sous jacentes pour
ce il s'agit de deep inside le spectacle
qui nous amène ici à la charpente bien
clouer au plateau voilà
[Musique]
on
pourrait dire que le cloud c'est une
oeuvre on joue à construire ce clown à
lui trouver un costume lui trouve un nom
lui trouver un maquillage
peut-être que tu pouvais parmi les
choses que je pouvais me dire ça va
faire c'est verbalement créer quelque
chose sur un plateau ce qui n'est pas
évident pour un clown en fait
généralement les clowns par le peu parle
pas très bien on des accidents de
langage
je me positionne comme metteur en scène
mais on part du principe que l'écriture
c'est boris parce que c'est lui qui
trouve cette parole au plateau
mais si rigoureux dans la façon de
regarder l'autre donc c'est pas toujours
facile à dire à l'autre manon ça ça m'a
pas mais je crois qu'on n'ose le faire
on a tous les deux les mêmes origines au
niveau de notre formation on s'est
rencontré un moment où
on est dans la construction de clown ça
a été le point d'entrée vers le désir de
faire du théâtre j'avais un petit peu
renoncer finalement je me sente de
révélations sur le fait que ce petit
masque la pouvait le faire exister comme
rarement
je
[Musique]
demain
comme tous les jours dorénavant
je mettrais d'abord des chaussettes
puis pour un athlète la vase c'est un
projet de seul en scène à partir d'une
nouvelle d'eugène ionesco je signe la
mise en scène mais en mai en
collaboration avec boris qui lui met
beaucoup sur le jeu à chaque fois ils
pensent qu'il a trouvé la solution à
chaque fois et à chaque fois c'est pour
la mode et c'est d'avoir la même
proximité avec ce personnage que lorsque
je travaille le cloud donc il ya quelque
chose de l'ordre du tragi-comique qu'est
ce que cela veut dire
il fallait faire un choix
spontanée un choix spontanée ouais
[Musique]
le clown c'est un état c'est la capacité
d'étonnement de réinterroger le réel
l'enfance finalement mais c'était cette
étape de redécouverte de d'innocence de
de joie aussi des excès c'est aussi un
lien qui se fait dans l'instant avec le
spectateur
serge blanco
sa plage naturiste
sont soumis sme de ses réseaux
son palais des congrès
ces espaces de coworking
ok c'est qu'aulas tiens
[Rires]